it is now one month since Anheuser-Busch
decided to destroy its best-selling beer
the best-selling beer in America
by sponsoring a particularly offensive
transvestite in putting his picture on
the beer can within a week
sales dollars were down six percent
volume was down 11 percent
but the company thought they could
weather the storm by doubling down and
refusing to apologize that turned out to
be a bad strategy since the numbers
continued to fall the following week
sales were down 17 percent in dollars
and a shocking 21 percent in volume that
was for the week ending April 15th that
was when Bud Light decided to reverse
course kind of by blaming a lower level
executive and claiming ignorance at the
top and sort of kind of but ultimately
not really apologizing they released a
commercial about horses or something
that didn't work either and now
according to figures reported by Barons
and bump Williams Consulting sales
volume is down more than 26 percent for
the week ending April 22nd
it would have been bad for
Anheuser-Busch if they had suffered a
one-week drop in sales over Dylan
Mulvaney would have been worse if they'd
taken a hit and sales didn't get better
but this is the worst outcome of all for
Bud Light they took a massive hit and
sales have just kept on collapsing with
no end in sight so what are the Geniuses
over at Bud Light doing now
they've released another offense
straddling commercial that says nothing
insurance
[Music]
properly diverse proud
all kind of ethnically ambiguous
they're in a fun field
fried starting to rain
[Music]
just a bunch of people walking around in
the rain easy to drink easy to enjoy Bud
Light used to be easy to drink now not
so much hey conservatives
you guys like blue jeans and that
Chicken Fried song right yeah yeah
show them that do that maybe put one of
the girls in a cowboy hat or boots or
something yeah those Hicks will eat that
up they'll forget about how much we
support transgenderism those roofs
they'll buy anything easy to drink no we
won't we won't and we definitely won't
be buying Bud Light
Anheuser-Busch is pursuing a strategy
that many a squishy Republican has tried
to follow in our increasingly liberal
culture Anheuser-Busch wants to stand in
the middle of the road they think the
biggest risk to their reputation is to
pick a side
after all picking a side with Mulvaney
hurt them
and maybe if they'd shut up for even
three or four days maybe they could have
weathered the boycott better but the
fact is
they did take a side on a major
political issue for which everyone
ultimately has to take a side do women
really exist as a real natural category
of people
or do they not
Bud Light shows the opposite side from
the one their customers are on now
they're paying the price they could fix
it by apologizing just apologize
just say that you oppose transgenderism
and that you support reality that would
earn them lots of sales dollars from
their customers from beer drinkers but
it would cost them lots of social points
with the liberal establishment that runs
our political order and that's a price
they're not willing to pay so Bud Light
Is straddling the fence dressing and
cross-dressing in blue jeans and skirts
lukewarm on a fundamental issue neither
hot nor cold as conservative spew Bud
Light out of their mouths let it be a
lesson to us all right now go to
geniusell.com Knowles are you looking
for the perfect Mother's Day gift that
will make the women in your life feel
pampered and appreciated our friends at
Jen you sell have you covered
geniusell's most popular package is
specially curated to nourish and
rejuvenate skin right now they're
offering 70 7-0 off this package which
includes their Ultra retinol and Dark
Spot Corrector our producer Jacob uses
geniusell's Ultra retinol and nighttime
moisturizer that contains a powerful
retinol alternative to visibly reduce
the appearance of Fine Lines wrinkles
and skin discoloration without the
irritation of retinol it leaves producer
Jacob looking much brighter and much
more even than he otherwise would
younger healthier more vibrant than ever
I love all of Jamie cell's products I
particularly love their under eye bag
treatment because I only consume tobacco
and alcohol and black coffee so it does
it really helps I I really love
geniusell go check it out right now
especially because I love their founder
who's a Coptic Christian from Egypt who
came over for the American dream
geniusell's most popular package during
their mother day sale is 70 off at
genucel.com Knowles every most popular
package features their Ultra retinol and
Dark Spot Corrector get a complimentary
spot Essentials box with every package
from now until Mother's Day that'll even
upgrade you to free priority shipping
geniusell.com
Knowles it's not just Bud Light
is Disney this is a story from last week
I'm thrilled that I get to report it
this week I don't want to let this one
slip through the cracks Disney has cut
15 of entertainment staffers
15 percent
why is that
well it's from a report in Bloomberg
it's a Disney CEO Bob Iger announced a
couple of months ago that Disney was
going to have to lay some people off as
part of a strategic realignment to
reduce costs why do they have to reduce
costs because the company's stock price
has declined to 17 over the past year
and Disney viewers they're not they're
not the same customers as the Bud Light
customers
apparently there's some substantial
overlap
but you think of Bud Light you think
Frat Boys construction workers normal
people of course
going trans was going to affect their
sales numbers but Disney
the the adults that I know who like
Disney are pretty lib
and Disney's mostly made for kids but
kids have parents and maybe the parents
don't like the idea of Disney shoving
transgenderism down their throat in any
case 17 down not good numbers for them
how did Disney find themselves in this
mess well because the people of Florida
passed a simple bill that said hey
teachers bureaucrats apparatchics of the
liberal State we don't want you to trans
our kids so you don't get to trans our
kids anymore they pass that through
their representatives Disney said
hell yes we're going to trans your kids
it's the obedo or a work line hell yes
oh yes we're going to take your guns and
trans your kids
and the parents don't like that and so
the parents are not giving Disney their
dollars anymore
they're they're giving their dollars to
other places they're giving their
dollars to people who are making kids
content that is free from all this woke
craziness people like
Jeremy and the daily wire over here
and it shows you a lesson that the
people are largely on our side
yes people who buy the regular old
conservative products
even the Disney people are on our side
the vast majority of Americans know that
transgenderism is fake it's not real
according to Pew research
sixty percent of Americans think that
your gender
just comes from your biological sex and
that's all there is to it I wish that
number were higher
but the number is moving in the right
direction because two years ago that
number was only 56 percent and six years
ago that number was only 54 so a clear
majority of Americans think this the
numbers are moving in the right
direction and if we just keep that
pressure up as we are doing successfully
against some of the biggest companies in
the country against the best-selling
beer in the country the corporations are
going to get that message and either
they'll Shape Up
or what's more likely because even
though they want to sell their product
they don't want to
irritate the liberal establishment that
runs our political order the alternative
is you're going to get an alternative
economy
like you're seeing here at DW and like
you're seeing other people do as well I
know I know what you're thinking that
was a great clip I'm with you if you
want the whole show you got to subscribe
if you want all that extra content you
got to ring that Bell ding that dong
click that thing
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time
[Music]